so we got to do something a little
different today
oops got some control stuff that
needs looking at
at least I'm going to take a look at
this now and then depending on where I
get
um I might do something else in the
afternoon but for
now got to make a little progress
here oh and hang on there were a couple
quick emails I just needed to reply on
the side
perfect and one last thing before we get
started I just had to say one one
Discord message
okay so what we're going to do at the
moment is we're going to
take this
I do have this
here but evidently not in poer lib
just make sure I'm not missing anything
here
so today we're going to be working on at
least for a good chunk of today we're
going to be working on the Isaac gym
stuff so this is uh humanoid robotics
control Sim in
simulation with puffer
lib um this is Joint work with the
collaborator of mine and he has sent
over some cleaned up code uh basically
what happened here is he started working
on digging through some of these
academic code bases I put together a
dramatically cleaned up environment
wrapper that was like less than half the
code of the original and a fair bit
faster and then he went through and he
cleaned up a bunch of the other stuff
around these so now we get to look at
this
phc hang on I got to figure out what he
did here though because he's got this
not in puffer Li
on yeah yeah this is what I did okay so
he
took no he didn't take this stuff this
is
I'm so
confused yeah this is
24 why is this back to 2,000
lines hang on maybe this isn't his code
okay I'm going to go run this but
I I'm pretty confused
wait just making sure this isn't going
to break
I'm hoping that this isn't going to
download some like Weird elf version of
torch or
something let me see if I can even
figure this
out and it's just like they should be in
the puffer repo
already okay so this is like reasonable
I see what's at least done here
this is the only one where I'm just
like I'm
confused cuz hang on right if I just go
to
up hey how's it
going I'm trying to figure out what Kung
did with my code here
see I took them out of the whole bunch
of confusing methods and I can't tell if
he put them back
it okay yeah no he just didn't use it
because this wouldn't be
here but he did use some of it so now
I'm just very
confused so he clearly read through the
end
stuff so basically I don't know what he
did here
how long should writing an end like pong
uh I don't know cuz I didn't do pong I
can tell you how long the M's that I
wrote took the grid took the grid M I
had already a prototype of it like of a
much simpler version that had like a
just it had a bunch of dated stuff but I
had some structure in place
and then actually um making that work
and adding the Maze and stuff that took
like two
days
um long
take I don't know most most of the small
LS are going to be between like a day
and a half and you know 3
days most of the small
currently attempting to get the uh this
new code Branch with Isaac Jim and Isaac
Sim
running and see if we can finish the
puff integration with there's some
additional motion loading code that
needs to get
integrated to to be
fair the format that the code in now is
in now looks like it will mostly be a
drop
in but there's still too much of
it but what we should be able to do from
this is at least get basic training
working and um
we should be able to do at least one of
the easier imitation tasks So based on
motion data we should be able to at
least get the bot doing roughly what is
seen in the motion
data
um I mean the main thing with all of
these projects is just there's like the
academic
repos uh used as references are always
just so bloated that pretty much once
you clean everything up things become
very simple and you can do whatever you
want yeah not launching coins
man still not launching
coins I'm doing Ultra hper RL
here not doing
crypto I I also find it pretty amusing
how you always have
multiple people multiple X accounts join
at exactly the same
time heck of a coincidence then for that
to happen literally every time
look if you're looking for like a
cool like crypto thing to get involved
with have you seen the uh like the Teto
stuff
that guy seems to actually be
building some legitimate stuff and
trying to fund it with uh with
I knew him from before this as the the
admin of the C this guy he seems like
he's actually building some
legitimate like llm tools uh in C like
very high performance stuff and seems to
be funny it that
way I can't tell exactly what it is he
is doing
um it's it seems like he's mostly just
building he's just doing like uh llm
stuff but lower level higher perf I
guess which is
interesting yeah but that's not what I'm
trying to go that's not the uh the path
I'm trying to go here this is a company
we're scaling uh Revenue through clients
I have yet to hear anybody explain what
web 3 is concisely in a way that does
not make it sound
[ __ ] this is the problem
no seriously like if you were to go to
like open
AI or deep mind or you know like any
like serious AI people uh and like pull
them like hey is there is web 3 legit or
just grift I guarantee you the majority
of them are going to be like oh yeah no
that's [ __ ]
and the same that was the case for uh
web 2 several years ago back in the day
as well as well as mostly for
iot like it seems like there're these
separate hemispheres of buzzwords that
cycle
yeah I actually I was very surprised
like to give you an idea I legitimately
thought his account get H got hacked
when he launched the
Earth what's the end goal of the
project so reinforce M learning was a
thing before language models right
before not language models but before
like modern llms uh reinforcement
learning accomplished a lot of great
things go DOTA capture the flag and yeah
we use games for a lot of it because
games are a really good test bed but
it's also been used for like power
optimization and data centers it can be
used in manufacturing processes this is
here it's for animation
generation uh it can be used in just a
lot of unintuitive optimization
processes across a ton of different
Industries and it was working very well
without a huge amount of investment you
know RL didn't get billions of dollars
the way language models have but then
people kind of just stopped working on
it and uh what I'm trying to do is
massively revamp the space by making all
the RL tooling all the simulators we use
for training a thousand times faster and
then enabling us to do really really
really exhaustive experiments in science
uh in order to figure out the places
that RL didn't work before and make this
way more stable way easier to get
working on new problems and way more
useful for tons and tons of different
Industries so really this is my effort
to revamp a whole sub field of
AI it's pretty cool cuz you can actually
like this is something you you can
actually do without having to raise
hundreds of millions of dollars like we
have maybe tens of thousands in Hardware
at the moment and we will scale to
hundreds of thousands in a few months
but that's about all you need whom would
your will your competitors be we don't
have
any we don't have
this that's kind of the way I like stuff
I like doing way out there things it's
like if you're kind of just trying to do
something better than the next guy I get
bored you know I get very
bored I mean there are people who have
tried to do like industry RL things in
the past and there are like still a few
people that do but I mean the way that
we're doing things is so massively
different it's not even close to
comparable we have 20,000 lines worth of
uh sea environments simulations games in
Sea that we use for training that run
like a thousand times faster than most
of what is out there it's just a very
different scale and a very different
approach
R
tensor okay so this is clearly not
installing
so yeah I mean there is very cool Tech
around here and the reason I don't need
to really look to alternate sources of
funding is it's still pretty small you
know we have only got a couple of
clients it'll scale but um I mean it's
really the type of thing where once you
have a company uh using the stuff in
puffer lib cuz rl's really hard right
rl's like really really hard but as soon
as you start using some of the stuff in
puffer lib and as soon as I get my hands
on whatever it is that you're trying to
solve people say oh my gosh like wow
this is like so dramatically useful um
we'd be insane not to use this this is
where all the growth has come from
list index is this a consistent error or
is this a probabilistic
error how is it that when I put a break
point this stops working do I get a
different error
no okay I do get the same
error motion data
load
empty so assumedly this just didn't load
the data file and silently
right didn't send me
any data
files motion file load data motion
file oh wait I think that it'll be in
um hey
welcome how's it
going we are doing something a little
different today working
on where is this
working on some uh High High Fidelity
continuous control stuff with Isaac
gem okay so it's sample data
amass still watching really interesting
thank you
honestly like it's kind of funny
that when I'm like talking about stuff I
tend to get more people watching this
and it gets up to like eight or 10 but
then when I like I actually have to
start like really working on stuff uh
and fixing stuff which is probably the
thing that people can learn the most
from uh people kind of get bored but
it's like it's funny because I don't do
anything that's that complicated but
it's very very effective like yesterday
I took there was an academic code base
uh for a very good idea I spent like I
don't know 6 hours just picking it apart
and cutting down the code cutting down
the code and I ended up with like 300
lines of code instead of 2,000 and it
actually worked instead of being a
broken mess and it's like this is all I
do
done but yeah yesterday though the one
from yesterday was particularly
convoluted like I actually had a
headache after doing all
that unfortunately it is 7: a.m. in
California right
now I don't know if I'm getting this
data file anytime
soon can I get this from
somewhere I mean I
[Music]
see sample
amass are you active there yeah of
course
we have uh a lot of stuff organized in
there yeah carbs is crazy we will be
back to that that is um I think at the
moment that's the highest leverage thing
that I'm doing in RL um we have all
these environments this is going to be
the next highest thing because this is
going to first of all it's going to cut
down your training time massively your
experiment time but second of all it's
going to give you extreme confidence in
your experiments that you know if you
run something you're not going to be
wrong because of hyper parameters you're
always going to have good hyper
parameters and right now that is not
true in RL and in fact I would say know
a high double digigit percentage of uh
published RL research at top conferences
is wrong purely because of hyper
parameters
you guys already have clients yeah we
have a
couple I'm working on finding a few
more um I would ideally I'd like to have
somewhere between 5 and
10 that's about what I can
support at current
scale um and that would bring us
to I mean that would get us enough
Revenue to buy whatever Hardware um pay
people and like do what we
want and also it's more than that right
because like our stuff is still open
source so when we build stuff for
clients we're actually improving puffer
Li in the process in a very like in a
real world use case right so like this
stuff here this is actually for a
company that wants to use this for real
stuff that they're solving so we're
improving puffer's capabilities on this
front at the same time even if the hyper
parameters work very well on one of the
puffer M's isn't it unlikely that those
parameters are optimal for different uh
for a custom M you just rerun train you
rerun the
sweep and the sweep will be faster than
before
hang on got to go confirm the
thing uh what we are doing at the
moment counts as non-commercial
because this is open source
there we go puffer lip contributors the
ones who do client work too uh not yet
and the reason for that is that when I
am you know pitching larger contracts to
clients uh at the moment it is is I'm
pulling people like PhD students who I
have previously worked with extensively
on research projects so I'm basically
I'm pulling highly vetted people who
also have pedigree uh now in the future
it's what's likely going to happen is
from there as puer gets larger it will
start to be I start pulling in like
major contributors on like a uh on a gig
sort of a basis paid gig sort of basis
for building specific environment stuff
and then from there it's like as we get
larger contracts I might then be able to
bring in contributors on the engineering
side and it doesn't just have to be PhD
students that's all down the road though
I guess technically one of the uh one of
the people I'm working with now uh
for contract on the cont Contracting
basis was somebody who started as a
contributor to another of my open source
projects a while ago
download what in the
heck a ass
train I would like to know which of
these
uh it depends who you're trying to
attract
for the vast majority of people I work
with um tokenizing would be a negative
signal like it really doesn't do
anything for
future well here if you if you want like
a real response to that
um the space has to fix itself and
become associated with a legitimate
method
of as far as I see it like the most that
you could do with a token is you could
kind of use it to make a company public
without making it public um and without
going through all of that uh and like
for smaller projects uh it's kind of a
way to crowdsource stuff in that way um
but the thing is at the moment that's
not how this is viewed it's viewed as
like this giant meme thing where people
just like pump currency in and then
eventually you know people get left
holding the bag and it's all just like a
giant scam that is the perception that's
not my perception that is the general
perception among serious people in Tech
so and it's for the most part it is a
legitimate one as well because of just
the amount of grift in the space so it's
the type of thing where if you want uh
if you want this to be considered
seriously you have to clean up the space
in my view it's on the existing people
in this space to clean it up if you want
to bring outside people in right I do
not inherently have any interest in
crypto right I don't my interest is in
AI so all my time and energy is in
pushing a die forward so if the crypto
people want to push crypto forward they
got to do
I mean it's like the same thing as me
saying hey if some of you language model
people right if some of the language
modeling people came over to
reinforcement learning and helped us
build stuff right we could make this a
legitimate thing that a lot more
companies see as useful faster but it's
not on those people who are doing stuff
in a different space and being
successful there to come over right it's
on me and the other people who are in RL
to demonstrate the value of it do you
see what I mean
so that's that is the problem that
you're going to have to solve if you
want crypto to succeed in that way
because and you want and you need to
have like a very clear you know why is
this useful to me because it's very very
hazy it's very buzzwordy at the moment
you can't just go oh yeah web 3 right
it's like well what the hell is this
right how does this benefit a project if
I'm building something in a space and I
don't inherently care about crypto why
is this useful to me right if some
company comes to me uh with RL and says
hey you know we've got robots in a
factory and we are writing code to
control the way that they run around and
it's really hard I can go oh cool well
we can write a simulator of that and
then we can run reinforcement learning
on that we can train it on a thousand
years worth of simulated data and then
the robots will just move around
perfectly and here are a bunch of
different cases where stuff like that
has been done previously to to
superhuman levels right now can I say
that just yet yes I can say that but it
would be very hard a year from now I
might be able to say oh we can do
something like that for you almost out
of the box and that's the value
right you see how I don't have to get
the person to care about reinforcement
learning I have I get them to care about
the result it's the same thing
but again this doesn't make sense to me
either right um ready to build on
anything that is tokenized
I mean this is like you know this is a
new space it's highly technical this is
something that requires substantial
investment to build expertise in order
to contribute in right like the
contributors that came in that didn't
have any RL experience they put a couple
good months of work in building
environments seeing how RL models train
debugging things in order to get to the
point where they can now actually
productively reason about the outcomes
of experiments and which experiments to
run and things like this
so you know the people that we're
looking for on the development side are
people that are going to be interested
in the reinforcement learning
I frankly haven't been following his
closely since he tokenized because like
most of the stuff on X now is no longer
you know deep technical content it's
mostly just filled with uh it's filled
with like crypto
memes so in a way like it actually it
shifted the
space in a Direction that's pushed out a
lot of a lot of serious uh developers as
well right like before that happened uh
I would hang around that Community
because hey there're a bunch of
low-level people building stuff
and uh you know we're using the same
we're using the same low-l stack and
puffer now not so
when I got to figure this
out
zaro I mean what it looks like to me is
the crypto folks are making the same
mistake as like every single Tech
Enthusiast right which is
there are some people that you're going
to be able to get excited about the tech
that you're building right you're going
to be able to get some people excited
about crypto but then there is a much
larger audience right that's working on
other Tech very technical audience even
working on other stuff that you're only
going to be able to get excited about
you know what it can do for the thing
that they're interested in working on
you know regardless of interest in your
thing
nope I've never had to do that that's
funny and then the individual files
inside of this are zipped as well what
the hell
academics okay this is like too much of
a
mess I think I'm going to have to wait
for Chung
here to figure out how to mess with this
okay as soon as he's awake I will uh
he'll be up in an hour or two he's on uh
California
time so I think in the meantime I'll go
back to the other stuff I was doing
which is
fine maybe you know I want to at least
like read through some of his stuff a a
little bit more though so I'll be able
to discuss this more
clearly so let me see exactly what it is
that's going on here
so puff forel has this
demo this demo has environment. piy
which just includes this
humanoid and then clean puff RL which
is this is just our copied trainer file
from the main repo this is
fine any file
Yep this is a config perfect this is a
config in the same format as we use for
all of our other
minutes you know these layer Norm Tage
policies are always freaking weird to me
I don't I do not like these because
layer Norm is always
slow but
fine if the message doesn't show up in
chat then it means that either X or
restream ate
it if it doesn't show up on the screen
like right right here that I'm not
seeing it
sweeps you're doing are they like grid
search uh it it does include basian
optimization it's based on carbs which
is a an extension of basian optimization
to cover the set of Pito optimal uh
hyper parameter sets with respect to
cost of running the experiment usually
train time and seconds and then the
score output uh and we are making some
large changes to that code and to the
math of that in order to improve on top
of that as well we also have versions of
that without basing optimization that
still try to explore a parito front so
we have a lot of different methods
here it does seem like uh basan
optimization uh are the winners for the
most part from what I've seen
multiobjective it's not really
multiobjective it's just that you take
you keep around as a candidate set the
Paro optimal points that you've explored
so far and then you use those as the
search
centers right so the basics of the
algorithm are you start off by randomly
sampling some points you figure out
which ones are Pito and then starting
from the Poo points you randomly sample
points nearby and then you use uh
gaussian processes and some fancy math
to score which points you think are
going to do the best and then you use
those and if you discover new parito
points then those become new surf
centers performance and
time sure if you want to call that
multiobjective optimization whatever you
can uh it doesn't really change the math
and it it doesn't really change the math
or the
implementation I don't know people throw
around the word multiobjective a lot in
reinforcement learning and uh the areas
of ml that I look at and I've never
really understood why because we kind of
just run the same thing on them
anyways multi-agent is another fun one
as
well did the whole PhD on multi-agent
stuff and we use the exact same
algorithms a single
agent okay so here's the
policy here's the
environment so far this is not bad I
expect that is the environment then is
where everything kind of explodes
because you get this humanoid
phc which is here and then this is going
to import everything right POS lib
motion
lib and Tor you
thing do you think it's plausible to do
MCTS and puffer yeah
sure
um so all you would do for that you'd
pick an environment that you want this
to work for in puffer um there's one
change that you would want to make to
your environment to support this better
which would be
you would want to make it so that you
Malik instead of having a couple
different Maliks as we have now uh you
would Mal all your memory at once so
that your state set is just a mem copy
so you have really really fast State
sets um and then you would just like
look at clean puff RL replace the PO
portions of the logic with MCTS and then
you would have really fast
MCTS wondered if there Pito front with
only no parito optimality is by it's
multivariate yes by definition a Pito
front is only defined when you have
multiple variables um the point is that
it is the set of parito points with
respect to cost and score are the set of
points for which you cannot find
something that has both higher score and
lower experiment
runtime yeah but
xpct the um the idea with puffer lib is
puffer is not a giant repository of
algorithm implementations right we work
a lot more on lower level infrastructure
we work on other areas of things that
are like underinvested in stuff like
hyperparameter search uh we work on like
tweaks to existing algorithms for the
most part but the goal is not to just
have a big repository of all the
existing algorithms now that said you
know if you have an existing algorithm
clean RL has a lot of them right and our
trainer is based on clean RL it just has
some extra log in some performance
optimizations so you can just take your
algorithm code put it into our trainer
and then there you go you have you know
your algorithm with all our nice fast
optimizations
but yeah we're way more interested in
finding like the good algorithm
generally to use
everywhere then we are in trying to like
provide a repository of existing
algorithms that you have to try all of
them and so far we're based on PO CU
that's simple it works very well U
doesn't mean it will always be the case
we might just we might just need some
small modifications to PO we might need
to do something completely different
we'll see but so far this has been
good and you know po does have precedent
of solving very hard
problems okay so all this is technically
just to fix up the
data so if we forgive
this and there's some stuff to forgive
here because this is 1200 freaking lines
of code
this is 6 700 lines of
HC okay this is my code so I don't have
to read this and this is like kind of
portions of my code I think mixed
with mix with the original massive
code yeah so like this is the
original but he cleaned it up at least
so this is no longer calling like
super and stuff
but like I see so he's cleaned it up
he's kind of like unnested all the
horrible functions that were being used
in a way but he hasn't understood
why the functions were there in the
first place because like the only reason
to have these three separate functions
uh is because of all the horrible
inheritance that was being done before
you can just put the code here or you
can make it one function
like there's no reason to have a pre a
physic step and a post
now your functions are allowed to be
code J Puff
spaces so we just added this in here and
kept all of
this I mean I'd rather just this be
hardcoded because it's already hardcoded
to the base model so like this is
redundant okay so this is where you use
motion Leb
at least this looks like it's easier to
work with though
y I read this
before okay so I think I sort of have an
idea of
what happened
here and then I okay so I have an idea
of what happened here at least
cool let's go from here to back to the
cool hyperparameter tuning stuff at
least until kyung is up so to give a
brief overview of what I was doing in uh
hyper parameter sweeping stuff I think
this is the most important thing I can
work on in reinforcement learning right
now because if you get this right the
entire cost of running RL experiments
drops by probably a factor of anywhere
from 2 to
um and also you get to be way more
confident in the outcome of your
experiments just weigh higher confidence
science which is always
good so this paper right this is based
on Pito
optimality uses basian optimization the
goal is to discover the front of Pito
optimal points that is the set of points
uh the set of hyperparameters the set of
experiments for which you can't find to
be a set of hyper parameters that will
be both faster and higher scoring than
than what I have now that is the high
level of it um to do that there is a
very simple base algorithm uh the simple
the very simple version of the algorithm
is that you take some random samples you
find which points are parito optimal so
which points are on that curve I can
draw it real quick
so if this is if you have some points
like
this if you have some points like this
then the Pito points the Pito front is
like this right these are the points
that are Pito optimal because there's
nothing to the up and right there's
nothing over
here um so what you can do is you can
randomly sample some data let's say
these points come from random samples
then what you do is you start looking
around these
points you start looking around in
hyperparameter space and then you try to
put points here here here here and here
so on and then uh you can do this just
by randomly sampling experiments like
randomly sampling around these points
but uh you can also do a whole bunch of
math and try do
better I will put the current math on
screen we have made some changes to this
since
um we've made some major changes to this
Neil V to no mean
okay viiz Pi M
V2 this was the experiment that we
started on
last
yesterday let me look at
this there's quite a lot of math I'm
keeping in my head at the moment but I
will try to talk through my thoughts in
a way that they're at least somewhat
intelligible
um where is the
here it
is normalized for mean minus norest
normalized nearest burito
score I would not expect this to produce
that Gra
you should get something uniform along
this line from this function um I think
what's Happening Here is it's the way
the score is being
normalized normalize for me normalized
nearest parito
score okay this
Isen to be able to connect
me that's the thing nobody who I know
who is in my circle would do that they'd
look at me like I'm nuts right they they
would literally like they'd probably try
to like email me and tell me that my
Discord account or whatever I message
them on got
hacked do you see what I
mean that's the problem that you've got
to fix is right now you can you can only
like do this with people who are already
in your space because of the perception
that you have of that
space I mean because of the the
perception around that space that's the
thing to work on
I don't know it's more basic like
business than it is Tech and
uh I uh I took some like some classes at
uh the business school while I was at
MIT and I realized that it's you know
it's way way easier as a tech person to
just get some of those business skills
than it is vice versa it's very very
simple stuff
right it's like person you're talking to
cares about Hardware or AI or something
that's not crypto you're trying to sell
them because it's crypto they don't care
right they think that you're like that
your thing is a
scam you demonstrate value you try to
like you work to push out some of the
grifters or at least minimize their
impact you say hey this can do X Y and Z
for you people are happy it's very
simple
right you can give me plenty of examp
examples but the thing is like these are
just going to be considered outliers
until you shift the whole mass of it
better
right like yeah look if I were clever
right if I were if I'm a clever person
and I cared about crypto and I wanted to
fund something using crypto I could
probably come up with some cool way to
basically allow people to invest in a
company without having to be subject to
the regulations uh the normal
regulations via crypto while still being
legal that's basically what you could do
with it
um
right it's like you're you can IPO
without iping and potentially with more
favorable
terms and you can IPO on day
one um
at least until the government catches up
and decides to come up with some way
that you can't do
that I'm on your side
there you got to get the damn grifters
I think I need the inverse of this
function I think that's what it comes
down to is I need to be able to undo the
Quant transform
here but I don't really want to have to
undo the quantal
majority that doesn't make a difference
that's still being affiliated with it
but the thing is you again it's like I'm
doing legit Tech work here people see
that I'm not going to compromise that by
stepping into a space that's just filled
with grifters and
see even if there were some upside like
some substantial upside I'd have to
balance it against that
like there simply isn't a compelling
argument
I'm not doing nothing at the moment by
the way I'm still thinking through
this
um so I mean what's happening at the
moment as far as I can tell with
this this where is
it this here is the difference between
the score of this like of a point say
this point here and the score of the
nearest Paro
point so it's this vertical distance
except that it's normalized by a
quantile
transform
the only agreement that you're going to
get out of me right is that you could
have a really good vehicle in fact the
vehicle of getting like Community
crowdsource like projects decentralized
projects open source Dev off the ground
and running and well funded without all
the normal strings of VC you could have
something really good there but it's not
there at the moment
here let me let me tell you what this
would be like right this would be like
if instead of Hosting uh puffer
discussions and stuff on Discord what if
I hosted all of the all of the
communications on ham if that's even
still
around what would the reception be to
that that's about the quality of the
brand that you have
behind behind new tokens
back so hopefully this is useful
information assuming that you you know
you're not just purely trying to
convince me of this and you are looking
for that
I mean the whole meme coin shitcoin
pump. fun thing is not helping you know
if this is your objective like even the
existance and the prevalence of this is
not helping
I don't know the particular reason by
the way for um the dev ecosystem being
around Solana maybe there is a a
technical reason for it but as an
outsider if I were trying to actually do
that right if I were trying to actually
make that happen I would distance myself
as much as possible from the existing
mess I'd probably do it on bitcoin or
ethereum probably Bitcoin and you know I
would just I would work to push all of
that side
out
do how much money there is on versus
Bitcoin
way market cap for meme projects or
market cap
I mean again for all the reasons I've SA
you're not going to get me onto this
thing all I can do is tell you how I
would go about trying to fix the
ecosystem if I were actually going to
but like I'm I'm doing AI stuff
right I think I have as well in the
during this process I think I figured
out I think I figured out what is going
on
here so so this is a quantile
transform it starts by taking this
data and
ranking essenti it's almost like a rank
transform uh it just replaces each point
with the percentile it is in the data so
this would be like this is probably like
20% of the data is down here or 30% and
this is maybe
40% uh but then it converts it to a unit
normal so I think that what happens then
is the mean is going to be around
here and then it creates a long tail
distribution over here so the distance
between these two points is actually
quite large and the distance between
points over here is quite
small which is not at all what we want
okay big
number is that trillion yeah
wait yeah that's
again but where's the volume coming
coming from
you see this quantile
so I think it's the Earth
inverse is where we go
wrong but there's still an issue here
right
cost I think we need to use
cost okay I think I see the
problem I see the
problem okay so here's the issue
right for folks I think I've actually
figured this out in the meantime
which so this is the issue
let's say that you have one parito front
that looks like
this it's a
line this one would be very easy uh to
optimize because what you can do is say
hey if I have this existing Point here
and I have this existing Point here and
I want to evaluate the quality of this
point here as a sample
I just take this distance right I just
subtract the distance from the nearest
Paro point in height space but the issue
with doing
this is that you can also have a parito
front that looks like
this where it's pretty darn flat towards
the top not exactly flat but pretty darn
that then you can't do a vertical
distance at
all what if you do horizontal distance
instead so if you have a point here you
have a point
here it's this
distance this point still has to be
better but you can't use the magnitude
of the
Improvement I would consider doing it if
there were clear value demonstrated and
right now it's clearly negative
it's like why do I host all the stuff in
Discord CU Discord is like I is and is
recognized as the clear place to do this
stuff I think this makes me negative
money at the moment
M welcome
Captain I think I figured something out
on these
sweeps I'm trying to think if there's
anything wrong with
this there
with the way it is currently there's
like there's no way you're going to
convince me of this you'd have to change
the
ecosystem the only thing you can
convince me is that there's potential if
you fix the
ecosystem so the issue is that even uh
so Captain the issue is even with the
quantile transform vertical distance
doesn't give you what you want so this
is without a cost penalty and I think
what's happened here so you do the
quantal transform right and then you
pull it into normalized
space so it's uniform normal and then
what happens is like the mean is right
here and that means that uh the gaussian
has the long tails out this way and this
way so the distance between these like
these close little points here in this
normalized space is very large and the
same over here here so you end up
getting just a ton of samples over here
and it will very slowly creep towards
the
center is not what you want and if you
were to undo um the normalization step
and just have the quantile transform
well the quantile transform it just
gives you a percentage you just get a a
percentage of the data that you're
better so here you're better than say
40% of the data and if they're 100
points here you're better than 41 42
it's just like a rank transform uh but
then the distance you see between this
point and this point is only one which
is the same as the distance between this
point and this point is also one so it
really doesn't help you uh you still
aren't going to get the effect of
filling in the parito front if that's
what you
want if I do it based on cost like doing
it based on cost I think the only way to
actually get the predo front filled
in I mean the only other thing you could
do right is you would have to figure out
how to linearize
okay wait hang
on you now exploring hyper Prem not
really the cost space kind of but the
thing is they're
linked hang on is there a way to make
this
uniform Norm uniform linear
somehow okay the other thing I could
think of
right is there a way to
transform the score space to always be
linear
I think I just need to I need to work on
inverting this function because if if I
invert this function then at the very
least I can test it on
this because here the score space is
legitimately
in no man I don't I don't have any
addresses and I appreciate it but we're
not uh this isn't this is not donation
wear this is not charity wear this is
know like I'm really just not in
interested in engaging with with crypto
in any way around my
project the most helpful thing at the
moment is just like getting RL like
getting more RL people interested in the
project and deving environments and
stuff
um that's the main thing
speaking of which Captain if you're
still around we um I should take a look
at your environment as of late um yeah
there's a bunch more cool science side
stuff to be done
here so hopefully we can get that I can
take a look and help fix up any issues
with baselines on the on that
environment and get that added pretty
soon that'd be awesome it's a really
cool environment I'd like to at least
throw together a quick Shader or two for
it just to Jazz it up a bit that' be
oh
good it gets even faster that's all the
better yeah it just needs to be jazzed
up a little bit
what do we think the odds are that this
got this correct on the first try not
even remotely
hilarious it literally just like wrote
normalized scores and then filled it in
the same exact way that's so
stupid for
hold on let me see running into training
issues with large physics time steps
physics Delta fairly
large yeah of course that'll happen
right that's how physics
works you got to balance it you just do
the smallest you can get away
with is the ca
out what's
supposed to solve it
how okay I don't know how that
works yeah I know I've been dealing with
people bugging me about that for a long
time no it's not mine I made a post
about it um I I already made an
announcement it's not
clip that's fine I'm not no
token
look make an announcement about this
stupid
it should be able to search your own
post I don't know I made an announcement
about it whenever the heck they
originally did
it see this is what I mean though I
literally have like dozens of
DMs like
this and you think I'm going to engage
with this ecosystem at all of course not
undo is this
even I don't even this isn't even
invertible is
it I think I saw something in the
original code about this as well cuz
this transform is
not I'm pretty darn sure this is not
invertible
I'm on E I'm on
EST I get up between 7 and 8 usually
and minus exercise and food I uh I
usually work until like somewhere
between 8 and10
p.m. Deo it's that I've had a lot a lot
of people bugging me about this lately
and I'm just I'm not in that space
all I've literally have dozens of DMS
and I'm just trying to build AI stuff
here
yeah the thing is he's just going to
come back on another account I'm
sure I might just work off stream today
we'll see
this is definitely fairly distracting
though I want to get this stuff done you
see okay
so Target
inverse I really don't want to have to
use this stupid
transform I really don't like this
function that they're using it's kind of
a
mess is there something else I could do
with it let me
think than here
uniform I mean it's like a thing that
makes sense to do but
let me see I might be able to replace
this with something simpler because I
really do not like the uh the added
complexity from
this no did not launch that's
fake there is no launch
one I'm just going to ban all the new
alt accounts as they come in
that's
stupid got nothing better to do all
right all day okay man it's your life
not
looking for more Engineers for this
project it's all open source it's all
organized in the uh the
rank
bucket
CL unnecessary Quant
buckets does the quantel give you any
so all of our stuff is public right here
buffer.
a you can try out all the M's um if
you're interested in contributing join
the Discord and I generally suggest that
new folks take a quick look at the quick
start guide
here and start by building a just a
really basic RL environment to get a
sense of how things work especially if
you come in without an RL background
specifically there was a comment in
there
right using preserves more distance
information within the quantiles
you know at this point I almost don't
care if this thing works better it's
just like it's complex there's no
intuition behind this I don't see how it
fits here and I want it out of the code
base
um yeah let me I we can just run a quick
experiment as well to
see so get rid of
this for
what did I
use I used
quantile yeah I don't need quantile I
just
is is this going to produce dramatically
different
there anything else wrong
here normalize
near and know this is fine whatever I
get up whatever I apply to this will be
applied to the parito front so I'll just
have to wait and
see how this
uh how this thing explores outward
oh the thing is that this is still a
gaussian
extremities we will see doesn't seem
like it's really doing that
yet but um
here let's just prepare
this
okay so this thing is pushing up in cost
so that's something at least and then
we'll see what happens when we
unnormalized
40s well I think that because of the
rank transform
there's not a huge amount of
differentiation between the points at
the very end
right yeah there's not a huge amount of
differ okay so that that's a
problem can I
somehow well I have to undo the
percentile don't I
percentile this just gets us to
percentile and then we have to
unnormalized believe we have to
unnormalized
us so this is not
good but the other one wasn't good it
was just bad in a different
actually so this is obnoxious because I
think you
need I think you do need the rank
transform I'm pretty sure you do need
the rank
transform let me explain what's going on
here
right oh wait wait wait hold
on we can test it we can test it without
the rank
transform because I have linear data in
this test okay let me try this and then
I'll explain this at least should let us
construct a reasonable test and then
we'll see if this is worth dealing with
so here's the
idea uh we were doing this
prematurely so if you have something
that looks like this you cannot rely on
the magnitude on the Y AIS the score of
these points for really
anything cuz the Paro front can have so
many different
shapes but because we have linear data
for this test test and we know it is
linear data we should be able to skip
the rank transform now when I tested
this previously I forgot to uh convert
the data to standard normal so that'll
mess it up but now what I have is data
gets converted to standard
normal prediction happens in standard
normal space which is what you want for
Gan
process and then the unnormalized is
very simple because we didn't have to
deal with the rank
transform uh and then what this should
let us do is test the algorithm nicely
on linear data and actually get some
reasonable
results and then we can decide what data
transform needs to be applied to handle
uh different score
distributions right
oh is this doing what I think it
is this is
hilarious it's like laddering its way
down actually
if this is actually what it's doing it's
too smart for its own
good I'm looking at it and that's what
it's
sense okay we're gonna let this finish
and then I'll explain I'll explain what
I think it's
done that's
hilarious I think it's literally
gotten the algorithm is too good for
it's too smart for its own good
here it found a way to cheat my
objective yeah so the rank transform was
just screwing everything up I
think and now it's going to something
more
reasonable I didn't see like a bunch of
50s ever did I oh no they're 50s it
still should fill in uh there's some
other regions that should fill in though
do you see that most most of the points
are slowly working their way down 113
111 it's got a very accurate cost model
as well so it's very good at doing
this and then there are some other ones
it looks like it's also working its way
down from
82 it's working its way down from
multiple points
180 this is going to be a crazy looking
graph
the funny thing is I can't even be mad
because this
is is this a straight A straight screw
up in my
original no it's a property of the cost
actually in this
case
interesting it all comes down to the
scaling of the cost and the score if you
have these things to these two things
scaled correctly it should
work I'm actually tempted to now try
this on the log cost
so
funny so what's happened here I'm pretty
confident at this
point is I specified the
reward for this
experiment as the
improvement over the next lowest cost
Paro point so what it's done done here
is it's gotten some random samples that
are very high cost and then there are
some other points that are Paro points
that are like way to the left and it's
just going a little tiny bit to the left
and getting the full reward and going a
little bit to the left of that one and
getting the full reward and it's just
repeating that
continuously so it's like lading its way
down from the top
graph it started up here and it worked
its way down it started up here and it
worked its way down it started up here
and it worked its way
down so technically this is one of the
better results that we've gotten in
terms of coverage but um it's still
clearly not working the way we want
right it's making these little tiny
jumps instead of trying to actively
cover the Paro front
me freaking messing with my Discord now
[ __ ]
off
okay
so back to
this if the increment is divided by the
cost
okay I think I just need to think to
reformulate this objective a little bit
because the penalty term that I
introduced will definitely cause this
every
the thing is I don't want to explicit L
have a term that tells you to spread out
in CL spr space do
thing is I think that even difference in
rank could be really unstable
I think they're like they two
competing issues here
okay what if for now I just think about
this instance I sto trying to think
about the harder ones in my head at the
same
Point performance divided by distance to
nearest burrito point
capturing you really just want the
divisor term to have
cost be performance per
cost no that's fine the top thing can
have a divisor as
technically the algorithm would work as
is if
okay pretty much the only way you're
ever going to
get a filled in parito front is by
explicitly having a cost term I think we
should accept
that
so let me try
something
score
no times right
burrito we'll see what this does I have
no idea
yeah that looks good hopefully I did it
right
okay these predictions suck so I messed
something up
it just took a
while was
weird okay there's definitely a weird
boundary
issue we'll let that run for a bit
nearby I'm going to go use the restroom
I'll be
back um I got to do a couple other quick
things I'll be back this will run we'll
continue on this for a bit at
is and I'm going to actually I'm going
to keep this one as
well okay so this actually gives
us pretty darn even coverage
right
these I don't know what these
are uh we can look at that there a
couple of these like
columns this one's the one that doesn't
make sense to me right here
a couple of these columns
here but generally this is pretty nicely
man we're currently doing very weird
hyper Prem op
things I got one that like selects
points and then tries to slowly drip
down and
cost did you see the new
mazm it's pretty
cool I have it I posted it on
here doors well I wasn't going to put
doors in The Mazes right I have a mini
grid thing
right here's your initial maze this is
tiny
this this like mini grid style
task we have to get this key to open
this door
things I'm very very fast as
well
so I figur this is going to be puffer is
going to be doing some exploration and
possibly curriculum stuff rather soon uh
so yeah there's going to be
uh there going to be some things around
that also I should go check on uh
uh okay I got to go uh I might have a
random meetings on the books I will be